une journée productive pour l'organisme
humanitaire globale medic près de 100
bénévoles sont venus préparer des sacres
pas destinés à des familles syriennes
dans le besoin et c'est un canada nous
sommes très chanceuses alors je pense
que c'est important qu'on t'a les choses
que la personne qui n'a pas tous les
chances qu'on a ici chaque sac comprend
des denrées non périssables
une fois cuisine et fournissent un repas
pour 6 personnes sur le sac
la liste des ingrédients est en langue
arabe la recette retenue est celle du
moudja d'art à un plat fait à base de
lentilles de riz et de nous sauter une
spécialité du moyen-orient on a
travaillé avec des shafia qui sont des
réfugiés qui vient de la syrie on
demandait aux autres clients n'auraient
pas pour nous qui les jambes ils ont
aimé le gouvernement picqué qui veut
donner un bonne santé ce repas riches a
également l'avantagé d'être peu coûteux
puisqu'il revient à 33,7 par portion en
quelques heures
5000 sacs contenant 30 mille repas ont
été préparés
il devait être envoyé en fin de journée
avec 800 trousse d'urgence comprenant
des purificateurs d'eau selon les
nations unies plus de 13 millions de
personnes ont besoin d'être humanitaire
en syrie
la guerre qui fait rage depuis plus de
huit ans six millions et demi de
personnes vivent en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire due au manque
d'accès à la nourriture et à
l'augmentation des prix des aliments
l'organisme humanitaire globale mellick
en est à sa quatrième expédition elle a
démarré ce programme durant l'été 2018
elle espère cette année en 2019
on voyait plus d'un million de repas
vers les syriens et réitérer
l'expérience deux fois par mois
et si rose à nicole radio-canada donc